apple's next official event is now
rumored to be coming on march 8th which
is less than a month away from today and
that is extremely exciting since we've
been basically going through a little
tech drought over the holidays and into
the new year and as far as what we can
expect to be revealed at the event next
month we're definitely going to be
getting a couple of very boring updates
to the ipad air and the iphone se but
other than that mark german did say that
apple plans to launch at least one new
mac this spring and if you're wondering
if this could be the new redesigned m2
macbook air that we've recently showed
off in these beautiful renders don't get
excited because mark said that those m2
max will likely launch later in the year
so with that said i actually believe
that we are now 100 guaranteed to get a
new redesigned mac mini at apple's event
next month and before i dig deep into
all the leaks and rumors and my thoughts
on the design and how it's all gonna
work let me first go through all of the
evidence that points to a launch next
month first of all within mark german's
report he said that an apple silicon
replacement for the 27 inch imac is not
expected to launch until as late as
august or september which is really
unfortunate and with the imac out of the
way the other option is potentially the
new mac pro which everyone is expecting
to get released later in the year like
dylan dkt who said he expects it to
launch in the fourth quarter which makes
perfect sense to me so that simply
leaves the high-end mac mini that's next
up for a redesign and update and we know
this for sure because it's one of the
only macs that is still relying on an
intel cpu so it 100 needs to get
replaced before apple's two-year
timeline for the apple silicon
transition is over and on top of that
apple has already released their m1 pro
and m1 max chips which are the ones that
are expected to go into this new mac
mini so there's no hold up on the
hardware side but going even deeper john
prosser from front page tech was the one
who first revealed the renders for the
mac mini last year and he said it could
come as early as the end of 2021 and
that's actually what a bunch of other
analysts believed like dylan dkt who was
pretty sure the mac mini would be
released alongside the new 14 and 16
inch macbook pros but unfortunately it
didn't happen because apple wanted the
absolute most attention on the macbooks
instead of sharing it with the mac mini
and if this is true then it's very
likely that the mac mini could have been
ready to launch late last year but it's
just been sitting there on a shelf
waiting for another apple event so that
they could launch it because whenever
apple gives a product a major redesign
they almost always choose to show it off
at an event to get the maximum amount of
press coverage and if any product
redesign deserves a slot in a dedicated
apple event it's hands down the mac mini
because believe it or not the general
shape and design has stayed almost
identical since 2010. yes that means it
kept the same chassis for almost 12 full
years which is mind-blowing and i don't
think this has ever happened to any
other apple product so it obviously
deserves to be shown off at an event and
i'm gonna go ahead and say it it's gonna
happen at next month's event a hundred
percent guaranteed no doubt about it and
the reason this makes sense is because
apple still has a lot of macs to release
this year and only a handful of
potential events to show off these new
designs which include a full redesign
for the high-end imac a new mac pro a
new redesigned macbook air and of course
the mac mini so without further ado
let's jump right into all the nitty
gritty details about the mac mini
redesign and what we should expect from
it john prosser's original renders
created by ian's elbow showed off a much
thinner mac mini with rounded off edges
at the top but the most curious part of
the design is that apple is choosing to
give it a plexiglas top now this detail
is important because having a plastic
top will instantly make it easier for
the bluetooth and wi-fi antennas to get
a stronger signal because if you didn't
already know people have been having
connectivity issues because of the full
metal redesign that we got many years
ago and if you think the whole plexiglas
thing is wild it's actually not because
that's exactly what the original mac
mini came with so it seems like apple is
bringing the old design back and just to
confirm this detail leaks apple pro on
twitter shared some leaked cad files
that showed off a metal chassis with a
completely separate top piece that
matches john's renders and this detail
is going to be very important to the
cooling aspect which i'll get back to in
just a minute now moving around to the
ports these seem to be directly from the
leaked cad files and it's definitely an
awesome and exciting sign because it
looks like we'll be getting four
thunderbolt 4 ports which is a very nice
addition on the mac mini however some of
this doesn't really make much sense like
how these ports are way too close to
each other compared to apple's usual
spacing on their recent 24 inch imac and
the weirdest thing of all is how this
render is missing the headphone jack
which is present on every single new mac
model out there and it's even more
important on the mac mini since it's a
desktop machine that you can hook up to
external speakers so apple insider
decided to make their own render of the
new redesigned mac mini by apple
tomorrow on twitter which i've gotta say
look really really good and clean and
they even made a new render that adds
that headphone jack back in to see what
it would look like and i think the
thunderbolt spacing makes much more
sense here now i do expect this model to
come with the option of a 10 gigabit
ethernet port just like the current m1
mac mini and it looks like it's getting
the new magnetic power connector which i
absolutely love on the new m1 imac and
this detail is extremely important
because when apple added that new
magnetic port to the 24 inch imac they
also removed the internal power supply
and gave it a bulky external power brick
and the point that i'm trying to make is
that if apple was willing to remove the
internal power supply on the much larger
imac then why wouldn't they do the same
thing with the mac mini since they
probably already produced a ton of those
external bricks and if they do end up
doing this it would save them a massive
amount of internal space on the inside
of the mac mini for example if you look
at a tear down of the current m1 mac
mini the actual logic board that houses
the m1 chip and the cooling system is
tiny compared to the size of the chassis
itself and a pretty big chunk of the
design is taken up by the power supply
alone so if the newly redesigned mac
mini ditches the internal power supply
then there is going gonna be a lot of
room on the inside for a bigger logic
board and more importantly a bigger
cooling system now moving over to the
bottom side john showed off a completely
flat bottom with these nice looking
rubber pads and i think this totally
makes sense but the interesting detail
is that the exhaust vent that's
currently on the back of the m1 mac mini
has now been moved over to the bottom
and this also makes sense because the
new mac mini is so much thinner than
before but the big question this leads
up to is how in the world is the cooling
system going to work because with the
previous design the mac mini sat on a
rubber circular pad and air would
literally flow in through the crack
around the edges of that pad which is
genius engineering but looking at the
new design renders the bottom looks like
it's sealed apart from the exhaust vent
and even if there was an intake vent it
would be a bad idea for it to be on the
bottom because it could end up pulling
hot air from that bottom facing exhaust
vent but if you really put some thought
into it and take a close look at the
renders you'll see that there is a
perfect opportunity for apple to add a
thin crack all around the edge of the
plexiglass top and that can act as the
intake similar to how the current intake
works but on the top and located towards
the front and this would actually work
incredibly well because the air would
flow through the entire chassis from the
front to the back and through the
exhaust vents for optimal cooling of the
chips and speaking of the chips i don't
expect it to get anything more than the
current m1 pro and m1 max chips that we
already have on the macbook pros so the
performance should be identical to those
laptops and in terms of the pricing i
personally expected to come in at 1299
for the base model with the m1 pro chip
which will likely be binned just like
the base 14 inch macbook pro and to be
honest that's still a very good deal
considering the amount of power and
optimization that you're getting now if
you disagree with my idea of the
redesigned mac mini getting revealed at
next month's apple event then let me
know your thoughts down in the comment
section below but if you enjoyed this
video go ahead and click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]